[Music]
hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what is making the
headlines with the observer's chief
leader writer sonia soder and the chief
executive of conservative home mark
wallace great to see both of you so
let's uh crack on with the front pages
shall we starting with the guardian it
leads with boris johnson's assertions
that his successor will certainly act to
help households over the cost of living
crisis
the eye reporting on front-runner liz
truss softening her position on giving
households money directly to help them
wither out the crisis
the metro quotes the consumer champion
martin lewis describing what he calls a
zombie government which he believes
isn't doing enough to tackle the problem
but the daily express thinks liz trust
will the headline in liz we trust the
daily telegraph warns the government's
income tax freeze will amount to a
stealth tax on pay rises in light of
rising inflation
according to the financial times liz
trust is poised to be at odds with the
bank of england after suggesting the
ministers in her would-be cabinet could
be given the power to overrule city
regulators if they think the progress of
brexit is being held back
the sun is leading with the trial of
former manchester united star ryan giggs
who's accused of controlling and
coercive behavior towards his girlfriend
as well as assault charges that he
denies that also makes the front of the
mirror
while the times says some universities
have withdrawn books with challenging
content from course reading lists
and the star issues a red alert over the
upcoming heat wave likely referring to
the risk of sunburn while the met office
has issued an amber warning for hot
weather
quick reminder by scanning the qr codes
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you watch our guests so let's go
to them shall we we're joined by sonia
soder and mark wallace welcome then to
both of you um mark let's go to the
metro shall we martin lewis has stepped
in on the cost of living criticizing the
government for being
effectively zombie style
really this is the issue for the
conservative party and the leadership
contest right now
indeed and also it must be said for the
opposition for the whole of politics and
obviously for all of us including all
the viewers tonight and being hit in
their pockets anybody but anybody in
politics can tell you the one person
whose endorsement a politician really
wants and the one person whose criticism
they absolutely fear in britain today is
martin lewis frankly because firstly he
has a vast audience secondly people
trust him because he's built up that
strong reputation with his expertise
we've given people those advice and also
of course because the very things he's
talking about in age of consumer
politics are the fundamental questions
of paying your bills consumer rights and
frankly
the two particular frustrations from my
point of view about this firstly this
has been a long such a long time coming
even i not an economist was writing
about this well over a year ago this was
going to be the dominant uh factor in
our politics postcovid the cost of
living crisis that was obviously on the
way even before uh the ukraine war the
second frustration is that when he
criticized the idea of a zombie
government that's understandable the
fact is this leadership race was
necessary but it shouldn't take as long
as it is taking and everybody's heard
all of the arguments everybody's heard
what both sides have to say and i think
quite a lot of people increasingly want
this election to be leadership race to
be done and dusted and the new prime
minister whoever there may be to be able
to get on with the job yes and the times
picks up on this as well um just reading
that first paragraph liz trust has been
urged to ditch outrageous claims that
tax cards will deal with energy price
rises after she continued to hold out
against immediate help with bills
yesterday this is martinez once again um
saying that the uh the front runner to
become prime minister must set out
detailed plans this month an offer to
help draw them up um for her so will she
hold um firm do you think even boris
johnson suggesting whoever takes charge
will have to to dig in and help out
further sonia
well i think she's going to have to give
in at some point the question is just
when and it's totally unsustainable
actually we're seeing her still go out
still trot out the same old lines but
tax cuts are going to help although as
molten lewis and many many other experts
and economists have pointed out these
tax cuts do not help those most in need
because pensioners low-paid parents they
don't earn enough to pay the sorts of
taxes that she's talking about cutting
and even those families who do earn
enough to pay tax the amount they're
saving will not come close to how much
they're forecast to to lose out uh it
now looks like and the average energy
bill will be four thousand two hundred
pounds a year by january and that's
going to last into march i mean this is
really going to be existential for a lot
of families huge energy bills that we
wouldn't have even really been able to
have conceived of two years ago and the
very depressing fact of the matter is is
that we've got the leading candidate to
be prime minister essentially standing
up and continuing to say um that she's
not prepared to
to provide the help that families need
and i just think it's appalling and
completely unsustainable really and i
think she will have to uten at some
point that's shown by the fact i think
you know the guardian we're going to
next leads on the fact that boris
johnson has intervened in in this debate
the fact that even the current prime
minister is saying she's going to have
to step in shows just how unsustainable
it is yes let's take a look at the
guardian um then shall we uh in fact um
brush johnson there um you know the new
pm will sir is will will certainly have
to bail out households over the cost of
living just just explain for us if you
can mark you know this reliance on the
idea of tax cuts being the solution you
know in some senses it feels like the
pandemic called for big government and
willie liz trust sees it as her role to
take
the conservative party back to their to
their roots of small government and
allowing people to have more money in
their pockets as she puts it
will it deliver quickly enough and um
you know will it be the solution that
people are looking for
well i think it is an important
principle an important conservative
principle that taxes ought to be low and
that the money
that people earn is better spent by
themselves when when is their money
spending in their interest then the
state will often spend it well i
disagree with sonia is this idea that
tax cuts are of no use whatsoever the
fact is that it's quite an uncomfortable
truth that in over the last decade or
more people on all sides of politics
have deliberately set out as a policy
goal to use taxes and levies taxes in
another name deliberately to increase
the cost of energy both for business and
for consumers and households that has
been a deliberate intentional policy
that's why governments have taken pride
in adding extra costs onto people's
energy bills um that is now are you
talking about the green are you talking
about which bit which bit of the bill
are you talking about you talking about
green levees is that the bit they've
taken pride in
well i i agree green levees being one
part of that yes the fact is that when
people have talked about deterring
energy usage a major measure in that has
been in doing things like green green
levees and applying taxes the fact is
that green taxation has been seen as a
as a syntax it's kind of transitioned
into being a syntax like uh the tax on
alcohol and tobacco and so on that's
been an intentional policy deliberately
to raise the cost of energy so undoing
those things at a point at which the
cost of energy is clearly becoming
cripplingly or is already cripplingly
high and is getting uh even even worse
that is part of the solution liz trust
is right to suggest that the wider
debate now is whether that is the
absolute limit of what needs to be done
or what can be done or not so i frankly
i think you're right that there will be
uh other action over over and above that
i don't think it's true to say that
removing those taxes
it can't be part of that picture frankly
if you're taking measures to give people
either give people money directly to
help with their energy bills or
effectively provide capital uh that
reduces the company that takes money off
the top of people's energy bills it'll
be ridiculous to do that while also
gouging people's energy bills in taxes
at the same time i mean do both yes i
suppose everybody wanted to encourage
people to move away from fossil fuels
was the idea partly behind that wasn't
it which seemed like um you know
certainly a good good idea in principle
but in terms of the other
element that people are pushing on which
is you know removing the national
insurance increase um sonia you know
does rishi sooner need to come out
fighting and say hang on a minute that
is going towards social care and social
care is the one thing that might help
might help the nhs by getting people out
of hospital more quickly
well i certainly don't think it makes
sense to be cutting a tax like national
insurance right now i mean just to go
back to
how you support people so the people
that it is most important to support are
families onto low and mid on low and
middling incomes and pensioners and the
best way to get support to them if
you've got a certain amount of money to
spend is to target it through tax
credits to benefits
and you can do that actually you know
right up to middle income families
through the universal credit system
because a surprising number of families
actually because their wages aren't
enough to support their families
are entitled to universal credit from
the government so that is the whole
point it's much much more efficient to
do it through a targeted means rather
than through lifting levies and cutting
taxes like national insurance which
actually help more affluent families a
lot more than less affluent families so
that's really the point about this
but you know liz trust has tried to
claim well it would be much less
efficient the fact of the matter is we
have an excellent and efficient system
for targeting families in need is called
universal credit the government has used
it before rishi sunak has used it to
target support on the families that need
it and i'm afraid it just doesn't wash
when liz trust kind of tries to make out
that there isn't a system the fact of
the matter is if people are paid so
little if they're if you've got low paid
parents in minimum wage jobs working
full-time they're not earning enough to
pay tax that's because um you know
they're on such low incomes in the first
place and i think this trust has implied
oh well you know we're cutting taxes
because we're helping people doing the
right thing i think that's actually an
insult to parents who are working very
hard but in very low paid jobs um
and who actually need the support the
most so is it would it be impossible for
two candidates who are trying to woo
conservative members to offer a change
in benefits is that is that the
difficulty because the narrative has
almost become you know shirkers and
shriver and strivers um so his benefit's
really not part of the debate right now
mark
no i i don't think that's the case i i
should say i've never heard a
conservative um minister or mp never
mind a leadership candidate use the word
circus for example that's a word also
often used to caricature their views
you know rather than what i've ever
heard them say themselves and i think
they that yeah
frankly as i said before sonia's right
that there is clearly going to be extra
direct assistance given that part of the
the question of sonia put it is when
that that change is going to happen on
things like national insurance and
income tax there are some changes you
could uh also make the ifs the institute
of fiscal studies in the telegraph and
in tomorrow's telegraph makes the point
that actually uh with inflation roaring
as it is raising uh thresholds on on
various different tax bands is an
important way to help people one of the
reasons that the people on the very
lowest incomes of course are not
wouldn't benefit from a cut in the rate
of income taxes that quite rightly from
the coalition years onwards the the
threshold to start paying income tax was
raised if people's wages rise and those
thresholds stay the same and then you
have what's called fiscal drag and
effectively people are dragged into
either into into paying attacks or in a
higher bands attacks and particularly
the bottom line under that pile you
should ensure that you're protecting
against that remember of course the
exchequer and the tax man do well out of
inflation in various other ways you know
when when you see the price the price of
your fuel rising uh rapidly that means
fuel duty and the vat you pay on it as
well are also going up so they have some
other sources of extra money coming in
okay well i mean in some senses it's a
fascinating debate which is being
prompted by the conservative leadership
campaign isn't it and there's the eye as
well just quickly um trust softens on
handouts for cost of living i am not
going to say what will be in
a budget later this year um that is seen
as her wobble room effectively so we
will we'll see what that and form a
chance to wish you soon also pledging to
expand cash handouts by a few hundred
pounds that was the news of today but we
move on after the break to this story
the fbi raiding donald trump's florida
home could he be brought down by
something other than january the 6th
talking about that in just a moment
[Music]
welcome back you are watching the press
preview with me now sonia soda and mark
wallace and sonia we go to the guardian
uh trump on the warpath this is after
the fbi raided his mar-a-lago estate in
florida we've seen the pictures um
outside of the flags being waived by
supporters and last night in the dark
that uh that raiding including his safe
he told us too um the question is what
will happen now whether this will
energize his campaign already we're told
that emails are being sent out citing
the raid as part of a way of donating
and getting more money from from people
yes it's just extraordinary isn't it and
with the polarized state of politics the
way that it is in the us i think the
danger is is actually that trump does
try and use this to his advantage as
you've just said
it pertains to
the fact that he is he stands accused of
uh taking presidential classified
presidential records from him when he
gets the white house assistant from the
white house to his private residence in
mar-a-lago
there's a piece of u.s legislation that
says that um all
presidents must hand that material over
at the end of their presidential term
and um trump stands accused of not doing
it which is obviously um a national
security risk but i think the fact that
we're even in a position where a
president stands accused of doing that
and you've got the fbi sort of searching
his private residence i mean it just
goes to show um where us politics stands
really and and and kind of how how low i
suppose trump has sunk um but i think
the risk is that it does create to an it
does add to an already febrile
atmosphere around trump uh you know the
potential for him to rerun in 2024.
mark i'm sure you want to come on on
that we've only got one minute left i
want to move on to the what do you
describe when someone doesn't like the
word retirement um impending retirement
countdown to retirement is how the
guardian has put it um how's the uh the
financial times doing yes grandslam
legend williams to retire they say um
she described described it as evolving
away from tennis didn't she
yes i i don't think there's a problem
with calling this retirement it's okay
isn't it i kind of think it's better to
be uh frank and upfront rather rather
than euphemistic you know they haven't
um you know passed on to the other side
it's just kind of ending one career
moving to another and what a career you
know that that that should be
the focus of this from the last century
all the way through to 2022 and we're
still chasing that that record of
margaret courts of course and there's
still time it might happen